Hello, everyone.
It is
an honor to join you
in commemorating
the life and legacy of Ed Zigler.
Ed was a mentor, teacher and friend.
His work has been inspirational to me
and many others in our field, and his profound
influence extends well beyond psychology.
For me,
he set an example of how science and policy
can join hands to benefit the lives of many.
Ed mobilized science in the service of the public interest.
I’m a— was a poor child.
That's why I became so interested
in the Head Start program.
I actually had my own Head Start program.
My parents
were immigrants.
English was not my first language.
It was back in those days,
and to this day,
there's a phenomenon in this country
that we call settlement houses,
like the Henry Settlement House
in New York City.
And these settlement houses
were actually terrific.
They helped enculturate
these families into the country.
Ed talked about his childhood
in Kansas City,
and he talked about being
the child of immigrants and being poor
and growing up
really in a rough and tumble world,
and how that prepared him for his work
and really inspired him to do the work
that he did later in life.
And he also talked about
what a good street fighter he was
and how that was necessary
in the world in which he grew up in.
We went to Woodland.
It was a demonstration school.
It was hooked to the Kansas City
Teachers College.
Reading
interest in the community, community services:
all of those kinds of things were part
of our curriculum and were very natural to us.
Ed invited me to have a beer
with one of his sisters,
Maurine Argon,
who was an interior decorator
living in the Kansas City area.
They called him Eddie.
It was a reminder that Ed was a human being,
in addition to being a titan of early childhood education.
I don't think my dad would have accomplished
half of what he accomplished,
if it were not for my mom.
She was a remarkable, smart, funny woman
who had to have the patience of Job
to be married to my dad.
I used to play, you know,
no-limit poker when I was a young man.
I quit college once to go to New Orleans
and become a professional poker player.
I didn't last down
there long either, but
the game we had in the department,
I beat these guys for like 30 years.
He taught me to gamble, very young.
Taught me how to gamble, play poker,
play blackjack, shoot craps,
bet on sports.
When Ed served in Korea,
he won enough money to buy his parents
their first home.
He won all the time there,
so he stopped playing poker.
The challenge was gone.
Plus, he felt guilty
taking money from his comrades,
payday after payday.
He broke his fast just once,
just once, shortly before discharge.
He played the camp's
pharmacist with the stakes
being the seasickness pills
he needed for the long voyage home.
He won.
But yea, I'm a very good poker player.
Taught my son when I was about
four.
He's a good poker player now.
He did give us all a strong sense
of the importance of social justice
and the importance of
taking care
of those people in society who society
otherwise seemed to want to overlook.
He loved poker,
but I think in many ways
he was a poker player in
just about everything that he did.
He realized that part of it
is about the cards that you're dealt,
and part of it's
about the things that you know.
But the bigger part of the game
really is about the relationships that you have
with other people:
your ability to be able to read what somebody else
is going to be able to give you
and to take a compromise when you can,
and some of the times know
that it's time to walk away from the game.
Ed Zigler had an amazing ability to work
across sectors.
He and several of his colleagues
from various disciplines
established the field of child development
and social policy.
He and I co-authored
the first two graduate textbooks that
defined the field.
I'm extremely
thankful on so many levels
for Ed Zigler's impact.
Of course, he's one of the most
impactful psychologists of the last 100 years,
really making an extraordinary transition
from mastering and contributing
to basic developmental science,
and then moving to applied
developmental science and essentially
creating the field of child development
and public policy.
The field of intellectual disability
owes its origins to Dr. Ed Zigler.
And the work of the Special Olympics Movement:
You know, my mom, the founder
of the Special Olympics Movement,
was always indebted to Ed, always,
throughout her life,
and called on him frequently
to ask for advice on the design
of programs, the evaluation of programs,
how to promote
and explain to policymakers
the value of these kinds of interventions.
Before Head Start, there were programs
for poor children in this country.
I think our Susan Gray’s
project down in Nashville,
Deutsch's project in New York City.
There was actually one in New Haven
that was sponsored by the Ford Foundation.
But what characterized those programs
was they were interested
only in education,
only in education.
And
what Head Start did was it introduced, really,
the “whole child” approach.
The “whole child” concept
first was articulated back in 1930
in a conference on children
that was being held by the White House.
And it was a concept
that was kicked around and people talked about
and I think people understood
the importance of it.
It's ironic
that it was first
mentioned in 1930,
the very year that Ed Zigler was born.
But it wasn't really until Head Start
that anybody actually took it
serious enough to actually do
anything with that concept.
It was an academic concept
that Ed turned into a reality in terms
of how we treat children and families.
Sadly, there are
little children
who are already headed
for lives of frustration and misery.
No one ever read them a story;
taught them a nursery rhyme;
showed them about colors, letters and numbers.
Beginning in 1964, Sarge Shriver,
who was the head of the War on Poverty, really
had this big committee that planned Head Start.
I was the youngest member.
“One foot right in front of the other.”
The thing that I remember the most
was about the wisdom
that went into the planning of this program.
And it all started
with the convening of a group
called the Cooke Committee,
and they had the wisdom to see that
you needed a healthy child
to have a child
that would be prepared to learn,
that you had to involve the parents to really
be supportive of that child's
development and learning,
and also that the parents, in turn, would learn
from being part of such a comprehensive program.
The Planning Committee was made up
of leading scholars from diverse disciplines,
including preschool education,
pediatrics,
child development,
clinical psychology,
social work and nursing.
The Planning Committee's
overarching goal for Head Start
was the optimal development
of the children
experiencing the Head Start program.
The Planning Committee, unfortunately,
provided
a very long list of subgoals
to reach this major goal, and this long list
resulted in the clear
goal of Head Start remaining ambiguous.
I myself, then in my own scholarship,
decided to simplify
by designating the four systems
that were absolutely most critical
in impacting human development.
First and foremost is the family system.
The other three
being the health system,
the education system,
and the child care system,
where so many children
spend those critical early years of life.
We had this big ballroom
in the New Colonial Hotel,
this old, battered hotel.
We didn't even have file cabinets.
Applications began pouring in.
We used to keep the applications
in— Off this ballroom were restrooms,
and in them were bathtubs, and we kept
the applications in those bathtubs.
Now, what Jule Sugarman did
that was really brilliant was hire substitute
schoolteachers, and they would sit there,
and they would go through the applications.
And if they had an educational component,
a health component,
if they had all the components of Head Start,
they would check it
and there would be like five checks.
And if they give could them the five checks,
the check for Head Start would go out to them.
So, in
doing that, you know that you had to put in
place a lot of poor programs.
Ed realized very early on
that there needed to be a way to be able
to bring people
into the profession of caring
for children and families.
And that's where he came up
with the idea of the CDA,
the Child Development Associate Credential.
We are still having the conversation
about what it means to create
a professional field
of practice for early childhood
educators, the competencies
and standards of early childhood education.
And I can't tell you how many NAEYC members
and how many individuals
who I’ve come in contact with who will talk
about the very first thing
that they did
was to get their CDA
and what that did in helping them understand
how deeply they cared about this profession,
how they wanted to make a career out of it,
and how it became the jumping off point
for these extraordinary women and men
who are now leaders,
system leaders, educator leaders, in our field.
It's really quite remarkable.
So, Dr. Zigler's legacy lives on.
It's an honor
and a privilege to celebrate his life.
We originally thought we would enroll
25,000 children in that first summer program.
Applications for Head Start
began pouring into OEO,
and we wound up enrolling over
560,000 children
in that first summer.
Head Start
was also very popular at the White House.
Lady Bird Johnson was the honorary chairperson
of Head Start, and President Johnson,
who was himself an ex-teacher,
was very enamored with Head Start.
The person who originally ran Head Start
was Julie Richmond.
Julie was a pediatrician
and my mentor, a brilliant, brilliant man.
At the age of 35,
I was hired by President Nixon
to run Head Start and to run the Children's Bureau.
I was Nixon's agent for all
children’s programs in the United States,
which the most important one
and the largest being Head Start.
I wrote about Ed in my book Preschool Education
in America,
reviewed his books,
and interviewed him for publications,
including a piece
we wrote together
on his early days at Head Start.
As he talked about when President Richard M.
Nixon
vetoed the Comprehensive Child
Development Act in 1971, Ed's
deep knowledge of policy research
all the players came out,
but he also knew the inside story.
He knew the bureaucratic infighting,
and he talked about it in a way that was candid
and witty.
Ed would give you
his opinions, rationales, suggestions,
and a wealth of evidence to back up his views
in an open way.
As he said,
his politics were children.
His goal was always to extend child welfare.
Upon taking charge of Head Start,
I immediately announced
that Head Start would mount
an improvement and innovation effort,
and that Head Start would become
a national laboratory
in which we would mount and assess
programs holding promise
for improving the development of children
living in poverty.
In my book, "Head
Start and Beyond",
which I wrote some 20 years ago, I spelled out
what a model program
for poor children would be:
a three-year conception to age three program
for infants and toddlers, like Early Head Start.
Then you follow this with a high-quality
two-year, full-day, full-year program,
which provides poor children
the preschool education they need
while providing Head Start parents
high-quality child care
they need so they can work.
In 1972,
I was a research associate
at HighScope in Ypsilanti, Michigan,
beginning work
on my first early childhood program evaluation.
It was a study of the new Home
Start Demonstration Project.
I was not aware of at the time,
but that was to be important
through the years in my relationship with Ed.
In the early seventies,
he and others in what was then
the Office of Child Development
in the old Department of Health, Education
and Welfare
were developing the first Head
Start Policy Manual.
Head Start’s most serious
problem has always been inconsistent quality.
Some programs are excellent, some are mediocre,
and a few are poor.
This situation began
before the first center opened its doors.
The project started off so big and so fast
that quality controls were left behind.
From 1965 to 1970,
Head Start had absolutely no
performance standards.
Every Head Start center was essentially doing
whatever it cared to do and whatever they felt
was Head Start.
I thus,
with the very first performance standards,
which lasted
till the Clinton Administration
when they were updated,
guaranteed that Head
Start was a genuine program
in which every Head Start center
did a certain set of activities.
And I and my staff
created the Head Start Policy Councils,
which must consist at least half of parents.
And these Policy Councils still exist
and are the ruling body
of each Head Start center.
Giving parents this power
has made parents
the most effective advocates for Head Start.
When President Carter
tried to move Head Start from Health, Education
and Welfare to the new Department of Education,
this would have destroyed Head Start
as we know it.
And it was parents who interceded
and kept Head Start in HEW
where it has had a comfortable life.
Poker is assessing people
when they're bluffing,
when they're not bluffing.
That happens in Washington all the time.
They might try to throw a bluff up at you.
Like that guy at OMB did.
That was just a bluff.
One of the most significant initiatives
that Ed and I worked on
is the School of the 21st Century
which forever changed the way schools operate.
Schools begin to serve children,
the birth of the child
through middle school and adolescence.
They also provide
various support services
in addition to academics.
Millions of schools around the country
are Schools of the 21st Century,
and the program also spawns
similar initiatives.
Dr. Zigler conceptualized
what is now known as Schools of the 21st
Century, or 21C.
Now in over 1300 communities nationwide
in rural, urban and suburban areas,
with year-round services
beginning at birth and focusing on the evolving
needs of the whole child
through age 12, 21C schools
create an invaluable platform
to build on for success in school and beyond.
The sad fact is somewhere on 35%
of all of our children arrive at school
not optimally ready to profit
from the school experience.
Too many children are simply
not getting a good preschool education.
Poor quality of child care
is compromising their growth and development.
So that if we can just use the school
as a site
where children can get good preschool
education and child care as well,
that would be a void
that is badly in need of filling.
The idea of the School of the 21st
Century is “why
should children go to school,
and then have to go to the doctor's office
someplace else
or the dentist's office someplace else?”
We know where the children are
—they’re in the schools.
That's where we should be putting
all of the services
that are affecting the lives of children
and families, right there where they are,
in the schools.
The Comer-Zigler Initiative is really an effort
to support the development of children in a way
that they want to learn and be successful
and they want to manage themselves in a way
that is respectful, helpful, useful
to themselves and to others.
The way our program came about
is that we were working in the same building
but separately
and had never thought
about trying to work together.
But we had the same foundation executive
working with us, and
it occurred to him that if
we put the two programs together,
we would be even stronger.
That program was so successful
that they were accused
of cheating on the state tests,
and they had to take it over again,
and they did better the second time
than they did the first.
It wasn't cheating.
It was child development.
It was support for child development.
It was reorganizing the system
so that you could
create an experience for the children
that everybody developed, and they could learn.
Ed was very much in favor
of having graduated rates.
Namely, that he would allow there
to be universal pre-K,
but he knew that
there would be a waste of money
if we gave this pre-K
to very affluent families.
First of all, a lot of affluent
families wouldn't take it.
And secondly, that they could pay in a way
that disadvantaged families couldn't.
So, he was very,
very enthusiastic about the idea
of having a graduated scale.
And to an economist, this is like a payment
schedule based on needs.
And so I thought
he made some very useful contributions to me,
and I incorporated that in some of my own work.
He made a real difference
in terms of social policy in the United States.
He was smart.
He was savvy.
He was connected.
He knew how to bridge academia
in the real world.
He was one of a handful of people
that had it all
when it came to early childhood.
He understood the policies.
He understood the mechanics of early childhood
and why it was failing, in many ways,
many of our families.
And in addition to that,
he understood the politics of Washington.
In 1978 Ed had been back from Washington, D.C.
for about six years
and had been completely convinced
that the biggest challenge
that we have in applied child development
is that people who understand
child development don't understand
much about policy, and people who understand
and are making policy decisions
on behalf of children
and families don't know much about the science
of child development.
And so in 1978, he got a grant
from the Archibald Bush Foundation of Minnesota
to create the Bush Center
in Child Development and Social Policy.
At the Bush Foundation,
we invest in great ideas
and the people who power them.
That is our tagline.
And it's also our strategy.
And marrying
child development research
with policy formation,
translating the science into strategies
to support the well-being of kids
and families, is a great idea.
The investments we made
in the creation of the Yale Center
from way back in 1977 are significant
in the history of the Bush Foundation.
And in our future, we're excited to continue
to see the long-term impact of this work.
The Smith Richardson Foundation's
long relationship with Ed Zigler began in 1986
when he helped the foundation
launch its Children
and Families at Risk Program.
At the time,
the foundation was concerned
about the well-being
of children living in unstable families
with low incomes
and limited opportunities for upward mobility.
We asked several leading social policy experts
to identify scholars
who understood
best what kinds of public policies
and programmatic interventions
could most effectively promote
the healthy development of children
from disadvantaged backgrounds.
They all pointed to Ed.
It was really Ed Zigler's
vision that created
the Bush Center in Child
Development and Social Policy at Yale
that we renamed
the Edward Zigler Center
in Child Development and Social Policy in 2005.
It was a way to be able to remember his legacy,
but it was also a way to be able to remind us
all of the fact that a good vision,
a good imagination can create things
that can have a huge impact
on everyone else that follows,
simply because you're impacting the way
in which they think about things.
The Zigler Center has changed the trajectory
of many people at Yale
who have participated in it—taken people
who understood
and were interested in science
and made them very fascinated
about how to move policy;
people who understood policy
but didn't know much about child development
and helped them be able to gain the skills
that they needed
in order to be able to be
the kind of people
who would be the leaders of the future.
I think in all of the people that I have met,
Ed combined these incredible ways of being,
He eminently was grounded
in his very humble beginnings,
and he was sort of scrappy
till the very end
because he always had to fight for everything.
And yet at the same time,
his being was hallmarked
by this consummate intelligence.
You would tell him something,
and he would remember it
a half a decade later, or he would come up
with profound ways of thinking afresh
about something.
So that I would say that
of all the people that I've known (and
probably most people
who've come in contact with him),
it was that combination of drive
and energy and inventiveness and intelligence
that really made him so incredibly special,
so incredibly valuable to Yale and to
the entire community that cares about children
and families in this country and in others.
Ed knew from his research that
the baby's first
teacher is their parent
and that they
need to form a strong relationship.
Mothers and fathers need to form
a strong relationship
with their babies, and their babies
so need to be able to form
that relationship, too.
And that's why the very first days of a baby's
life are so deeply, deeply important.
And that's why he cared about parental leave
and parents being able to take the time off from work
to be able to form that strong bond
with their baby.
He also realized in 1993
he wasn't going to be able
to get a paid parental leave.
So, he took a compromise
and he worked with Chris Dodd and other people
in Washington, D.C.
to create the Family Medical Leave Act in 1993,
which wasn't paid
but nonetheless protected a parent’s ability
to be able to take time off
and form that important bond with their child.
It took me seven years to pass
family medical leave without pay.
It was vetoed two or three times.
And Ed, of course, was terrific help on that
and could explain it in ways
that people would understand.
I was talking to Bill Clinton
several years ago
on the anniversary of the signing of the bill.
It was the first piece of legislation
he signed into law as President.
He said, as a former president,
people stop me all the time and say hello
and this, that and the other.
He said, the one issue
they bring up more than any other issue
was the fact that I was the President
that signed into law
the Family Medical Leave Act.
Of all the things I was involved
in, that's the one thing
they bring up more than anything else.
What we're realizing now is that it's critical
that families have access to a paid
leave in order to make it possible
for them to actually take advantage
of the provisions under the FMLA.
And that research
from the 1970s that he and his students did
is still the research that people are citing.
And today
we have over
eight states
that now have a fully paid parental leave,
and the federal government
has it for service workers.
We're knocking at the door
now on a vision that Ed had back in 1993.
He supported us in founding the Yale
China Program on Child Development
at Yale University.
Dr. Zigler had a lifelong commitment to providing
the “whole child” approach to education.
As in Head Start, the Yale
China Program on Child Development
aims to provide children a good start,
through cross-cultural academic collaborations.
Above everything else,
Ed cared most deeply
about teaching and mentoring
and making the next generation
of leaders to be able to carry on the work
and carry the work forward.
I had the honor of being in Ed's orbit
for 21 years,
first as a graduate student
and then as Assistant
Director of the Bush, then Zigler, Center.
My role at the Zigler
Center was running the Zigler
Fellows Program,
which trained Yale affiliates
at multiple levels
– undergrads, grad
students, postdocs, early-career
and mid-career – on how to work
at the intersection of child
development and social policy,
a field that Ed essentially founded.
I chose to attend graduate school at Yale
to be part of this fellowship program,
so it was really incredible
to eventually lead it with Ed.
We organized a weekly social policy lunch
lecture series,
which brought renowned people in the field
to Yale to speak about their work.
This was both a Yale course
and a series open to the entire Yale
community,
as well as to the general public in New Haven.
It was one of the first,
if not the first, Yale courses of this kind.
The series drew a large, diverse
crowd every week
during the academic year for decades.
The Zigler Fellows Program
also featured an annual trip
to Washington, D.C.,
where Fellows visited various players
in the social policymaking process
on their home turf to learn about their jobs.
We also had a small seminar
that Ed and I co-taught.
Over the course of just the 12 years
I worked at the Zigler Center,
hundreds of fellows
participated in the fellowship program.
Ed, as we all know, had an incredibly long
list of accomplishments.
But he always said that
his proudest accomplishment
was the many students and fellows
he trained over the course of his long career.
There are over 500 Zigler Center fellows
out there in the world
just from this one site here alone.
And they're in academia
and they're in government
and they're in philanthropy
and they're at nonprofit institutes,
and they're writing about child
development and social policy for newspapers.
They are all over the place
doing all kinds of different elements of work
necessary in order
for us to be able to not just talk
about how to help children and families,
but actually do it.
In my current position
as Chief Research Officer
at a national child advocacy organization,
I draw on what I learned
from Ed on a weekly basis,
and I'm sure that most of Ed's former students
and Zigler fellows do the same.
The Zigler Fellow alumni list
reads like a Who's Who
of the field of child development
and social policy.
Ed was right to be proud,
and I'm honored to be part of it,
and among those Ed brought into the field.
I knew from the beginning
that I was extremely fortunate
to have Ed as my mentor,
but I truly appreciated him
when I did a summer internship
at the Office of Child Development,
which he had led.
The first thing I saw when I walked in the door
was this giant portrait of Ed Zigler.
People there spoke of him with such reverence.
And over the years, I became increasingly aware
of the admiration and appreciation
people had for Ed.
Everywhere, but especially among child
advocates and practitioners.
Ed was a scholar, and he
advised his students to be scholars first
if they wanted to have an impact; to earn,
not to expect, attention from policymakers.
But at heart, he was an advocate for children,
especially children
who are overlooked and underserved.
That heartfelt commitment to improving
children's lives
is what people experienced and revered him for.
Ed was also savvy
and extraordinarily effective.
He was willing to collaborate with people
from every political side
to find common ground.
This is, as we all know, a
rare quality these days.
He persisted and regrouped
when necessary,
reminding us all
that we might not be successful
in a particular moment,
but we needed to be ready
when the right moment came along.
Ed taught us to remain vigilant
after victories,
because successes can be easily reversed.
He had a vision that his students
and everybody who worked with him
needed to be the very, very best they could be,
and that it was his job to inspire
that bestness
in all of us.
If I was working on a chapter
or working on a journal article with Ed,
I felt like the weight
of all the children of the world
was on my shoulders with this article,
that the lives of babies were in the balance
on the basis of
just some article that I was writing.
And I think it was really
because he carried
that kind of sense of urgency, too.
If you called him up, you better be prepared
for the answer
because he was going
to give it to you straight.
And I appreciated that about him.
If I was off on something,
he didn't hesitate to tell me.
He would edit with this big red pen
that you would get it back
and you would think, Oh my gosh,
am I going to possibly survive this?
My office was in many ways a home
to many students
after their encounters with Ed.
So, yes, it is true he was hard, but
it was always in everybody's best interests
and we all strive to live up
to his expectations for all of us.
And frankly,
I think he made every one of us better scholars
as a result of that.
Ed turned me into a scholar,
first and foremost,
whose activism drew from science.
So, what was it like being Ed student?
It could be terrifying at times.
He did not tolerate fools
or students
who gave up on themselves,
but he always had his students’ backs.
He always picked us up when we faltered,
and he always celebrated our achievements.
He was like a second father to me.
Ed is the kind of person who will tell you
what he thinks to your face
and defend you behind your back.
If you didn't know
where you stood with Ed Zigler,
you simply were not paying attention.
He would made it perfectly clear
where things stood.
But you also knew exactly why he was that way,
because he took it so seriously.
And as a result,
it was impossible to not take it seriously
with him.
I remember Larry Aber telling me before I even
applied to Yale
that working with
Ed would give me a tough, exacting,
irascible adviser,
but one who would remain steadfast
and loyal to me for the rest of my career.
And Larry was so right.
Ed was with me at every step,
writing letters of recommendation,
being a cheerleader,
telling me I could do it,
helping me to reflect on things,
and pushing me to take the next step.
In my second year of graduate school,
a family tragedy befell my extended family,
and I thought I would need to
drop out of graduate school to fulfill
my responsibilities to my extended family.
Ed asked, “Larry,
do you want to drop out of graduate school?”
And I said, “no.”
He said, ”then let’s find a way.”
And he promptly brainstormed with me
how to keep me in graduate school.
For me, remembering Ed
now is more about the ways
in which he welcomed, encouraged
and supported me
and all of his other graduate students
into the world of what I will call
provocative scholarship,
inextricably linked with impassioned action.
The admiration and respect that APA
and the psychology community have for Ed
are beyond measure.
Dr.
Robert Sternberg,
another former APA
President, awarded a Presidential Citation
to Ed in 2003.
That same year, Ed
was recognized with a Mentor Award
in Developmental Psychology,
and he previously received the APA Award
for Distinguished Contributions
to Theory and Research in Community Psychology.
Yet I understand that Ed
was the most proud of receiving APA’s
premier award
for Outstanding
Lifetime Contributions to Psychology in 2008.
I will never, ever
forget my first meeting with Dr.
Zigler when we were talking to him
about the idea that grew into Jumpstart,
the AmeriCorps program
that trains college students to work one-on-one
with preschoolers.
Of course,
we thought he hated the idea
and was completely unhappy
and about to throw us out of his office
based on his demeanor
and how he was interacting with us
while we were talking.
And then at the end, he said, “I like it,
and I'll give you $1,000 to help
get this idea off the ground.”
It completely changed everything for us.
He didn't just give us the thousand dollars
form the old Bush Center for Child Development,
he also gave us an office
right around the corner from his office,
which was the first Jumpstart office ever.
What started in that office has now grown
into truly a national movement.
Over 60,000
college students have served
as Jumpstart Corps members.
They've worked with over
120,000 preschoolers
all across the United States.
And I'm not sure that any of that
would have happened without Dr.
Zigler
giving us that first thousand
bucks and believing in us
and believing in young people,
which is one of the many amazing things
about Dr. Zigler's entire career.
I was very early in my career and participating
in a conference
in Burlington, Vermont, in which Ed
was the keynote, of course, as always.
And I had some very minor role. And
at some point during the day
there was a press conference being held,
and Ed was going to meet
with the local reporters
and invited me to come and participate.
And I said, “Oh my God, no way.
I'm too intimidated.
I'm afraid of the press.
I'm afraid that I'll be misquoted.”
He looked me in the eye
and he said, “Let me tell you something.
If you want to kind of play in this arena
and want to have an influence,
you have to put yourself out there
and be willing to speak to the press
and do your best at putting out there
what you want to say.
But remember,
never forget that once you say something,
you have no control over
what people do with it.
So you give it your best shot.
You don't expect to have any say
about what happens after that.
And if you can't handle that kind of pressure,
then don't expect
that you're going to be able
to make a difference in that arena.”
But I never remember Ed ever wanting
to be on the camera,
wanting to be covered, wanting to be quoted,
except if he thought it would assist
and help the issue.
Ed embodied for me
how one can utilize academic training
to continuously try
to make the world a better place
for everyone.
I look back on my career post-Yale
and recognize that it was not by accident
that those 35 some odd years
at the Hartford Foundation for Public
Giving were centered around
the development of policies and programs
to support young children and their families.
Moreover, on a very personal level,
my career as a father
has been shaped by his teachings, questioning,
and encouragement to deeply understand
and engage in this remarkable life event.
Thank you so very much, Ed,
for helping to steer me onto these
incredibly important paths
of learning, of being and of doing.
It's a real honor and pleasure
to have the opportunity
to highlight Ed’s impact on my life.
I was honored to bring together 23 scholars,
practitioners and advocates to craft an article
to honor Ed, titled “Pathways
to a More Peaceful and Sustainable World.”
The article provides an overview of selected,
ongoing international efforts
that have been inspired by Ed's vision
to improve programs
and policies for young children and families.
The efforts presented are
in close alignment
with the strategies articulated by Ed.
Several  years later, we found out
that Ed was going to need surgery.
And Dr. Kim, the anesthesiologist, went over to Dr.
Zigler and said, “I was a Head Start graduate.
My mother said that the only reason
that I turned out as well off as I did
was because I had such a good start
to education
from the Head Start experience that I had.”
After the surgery was over, it really wasn't
the kind of follow up
that sounded like a doctor
checking in on a patient.
It was more like a man checking in
on his previously unknown benefactor,
somebody that he felt
had really helped change his life.
The numbers people,
the numbers of policies
and the numbers
of visionary steps
that he architected
led this nation to a far better,
however still imperfect but
far better, agenda for children and families.
He was brilliant.
He was at the cutting edge of everything
and a visionary in every way.
So, we all have a lot to appreciate
and be thankful for.
Fifty years ago, Sargent Shriver,
one of the architects of the War on Poverty,
handpicked a brilliant young
academic from Yale University, Edward Zigler,
to serve as a leading expert
tasked with designing the program
that became Head Start.
President Johnson spoke of this project as,
and I quote, “a new war front on poverty.”
He said,
and again, quote, “We set out to make certain
that poverty’s children would not be forever
more poverty’s captives.”
Professor Zigler soon
became known as the “Father of Head Start”
and with good reason.
And even today, it is difficult to overstate
how audacious, how revolutionary, Dr.
Zigler's vision really is.
Head Start brings together
everything, everything
that matters most
to young children: education, health,
emotional well-being, nutrition,
social services.
Instead of treating children as isolated
individuals, Head Start embraces whole families
involving parents
and making sure their kids are ready to learn.
Head Start is without question,
the most effective early
childhood development program
that our country has ever developed.
His gifts to the United States
do not stop with Head Start.
He helped give our country, family
and medical leave, assistance with child care,
Zero to Three.
And, with Dr. Jim Comer, the CoZi Initiative,
the Yale Child Study Center.
But his greatest legacy
is the stars
too numerous to name
who have been trained at Yale
under his tutelage.
Ed left an indelible mark
on our community and our nation.
It was my great privilege
to not only have had the opportunity
to work closely with him,
but to have called him my friend.
And today, it is my great honor to join
all of you in remembering
Ed’s invaluable contributions
not only to his chosen profession,
but to all of our lives.
May his spirit and vision continue
to be a guide to us all.
When I'm asked
what am I most proud of
as a senator and author
of a lot of legislation,
I come back to children every single time.
Other things may have had a
larger impact at the moment and so forth.
But nothing I did will have the lasting impact
that the cluster of issues
around children and their families did,
and Ed Ziglr was the author
of an awful lot of those ideas
and how to get them done.
He wanted us to always do better.
He wanted our country to do better.
He wanted scholars to do better by our country.
He wanted those of us
who were in the profession
of teachers and school administrators,
he wanted us to do better
because he knew we could.
And he knew
there was a better future for children,
if only we dedicated ourselves
more fully to it.
Upon receiving one of his numerous awards, Ed
reflected on the Head Start program
he conceptualized.
He said,
“If I had never done anything else in my life,
that would have been a life worth living.”
But of course, Head Start was
just one way Ed improved our world.
He advised every US president from Lyndon
Johnson to Barack Obama
on child and family policy.
He was a prolific scholar
who published over 40 books and 800 papers,
and he was pivotal to the Family
and Medical Leave Act’s passage.
Throughout his life,
Ed brought much honor to Yale,
and an equal measure of hope to millions
of youths across America.
As we pay tribute to our devoted colleague,
let us find solace in the fact
that Ed Zigler's legacy endures
through the many lives he enriched.